they take now as we've had already on
the program the government's releasing
an app to try and warn people if they've
been near someone who report symptoms of
coronavirus but there are questions
about technical issues and worries over
privacy some people want their data
capped out with the government's hands
Michael Vale is a lecturer at UCL who's
working on a rival project to the
government and he joins us now thank you
very much for being with us now we know
of course that this NHS app is gonna be
really central to the government's plans
for easing the lockdown how important do
you think it will be and how do you
think the developments going so the
development appears to be running into
some problems with them different types
of phones so when we're developing a
system we're developing the system for
Germany and Switzerland in Austria and
many other European countries we've been
working in a way where all of the the
matching between people happens on a
user's device not in a central server
and that's generally considered to be
more privacy-preserving whereas the UK
has taken a different approach which
builds a social network of people in the
cloud the problem is the Apple and
Google Apple in particular have stated
that they won't allow this kind of
central system to be created it doesn't
work with their operating system and so
the UK is really going against the grain
and therefore is finding problems on
both Google and Apple phones as a result
do you think is right that companies
like Apple and Google should be able to
effectively dictate the UK's government
responds to a pandemic
well the question is no app was possible
beforehand basically Bluetooth is
commonly used to track people around
shopping malls or supermarkets and so
it's often disabled by default in the
background of a phone so it can't be
used when the app is off and Apple and
Google had to produce a response that
met all countries needs at once in
particular it had to produce response
where countries potentially like Hungary
which were lacking a rule of law in many
ways couldn't abuse their own phones and
so they had to propose a system that
worked for every country at once and
that was a system that mists that limits
what what governments can do and build
with that data in ways that can harm
citizens so we spoke to Robert generique
a little earlier about this he said that
the trials going well
in the Isle of Wight but of course we
also discussed this idea that a second
app is being developed just in case do
you think the government will end up
using the second app yeah there are real
signs that they might particularly
because the UK is a clear outlier
internationally in using this particular
type of approach and that means it won't
work well across borders the Republic of
Ireland have already said they're using
a decentralized approach and that will
potentially create problems there if the
developed administration chooses to
effectively put in this kind of app and
and so there are challenges there also
with it functioning in the first place
and public acceptance because the
problem with the UK's app is that it
creates a foundation for building more
and more on if this app doesn't work or
if the government wants to build say
immunity risk scores or stop people
coming into pubs or shops or going to
work without this app it's unclear that
this protects against it and there
aren't clear legal safeguards like there
have been past in Australia instead to
say nobody can demand you show this app
to anybody else realistically when do
you think this kind of offers gonna be
off and running in the UK I think it
wouldn't be anytime before June and
again it really depends on how the
trials going one of the challenges is
the app needs to be tested in realistic
situations busy situations and if the
Isle of Wight is in lockdown as it is
it's unclear that that is a a good
testing environment - to see if the app
really works and particularly around
issues like battery when there are a lot
of people around and it just functioning
at all and continuing to work throughout
the day which is not a problem the Apple
and Google based systems have but is a
problem of the UK system is facing I
also wonder as well do you think it
could just get completely overwhelmed if
people are reporting symptoms and then
the alert goes out or you might even get
some people reporting false symptoms
could you just see everyone ending up
having an alert and being in lockdown
that's definitely a type of the type of
risk the UK is also an outlier and being
effectively the only country to use self
reporting in this app not verified tests
that appears to stem from not a lack of
number of tests potentially but but
really something that hasn't been
focused on enough the tests aren't fast
enough
in the UK compared to other countries
and so the UK is seems to claim it's
stuck using self-reporting because it
can't get a test turned around within a
few hours and this is really a worry but
it's in the other countries we're
working with they are very clear that
self reporting will not be allowed on
their app because it can be misused or
used to pranks or use to target people
deliberately and put them into
quarantine without them knowing
interesting stuff thank you very much
for coming on and explaining all that
I'm Michael Vale